[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7000 sport
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire baseball
les cougars de montigny le bretonneux
ont débuté leur saison ce week-end par
deux victoires contre aunis dans le
championnat de première division pour
recevront l'équipe dans quelques
instants sur ce plateau apnée le franco
cubain andy cabreira aviles a une
nouvelle fois réalisé un record il a
passé moins de cinq minutes à respirer
pendant six heures pour défendre la
cause animale reportage à suivre
rugby versailles a fêté à la main sa
montée en fédérale 3 ce week end devant
plusieurs centaines de supporters pour
l'occasion les joueurs de la cité royale
se sont imposés contre clichy certains
membres de l'équipe seront avec nous sur
ce plateau pour nous parler de cette
page de l'histoire du club
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par du baseball et
cougar de montigny le bretonneux
finaliste malheureux la saison passée de
première division ont réussi à leurs
débuts ce dimanche ils se sont imposés 9
à 0 et 9 à 2 contre nice sur les deux
matches chocs pour nous parler de cette
performance et des objectifs du club
nous recevons sur ce plateau le
président franck lecarpentier le coach
rodolphe le meur ainsi que deux joueurs
ailleurs franck lopez et gabriel do
carmo bonsoir alors est ce que ce match
contre nice était si simple coach
l'image sont jamais simples c'est vrai
qu'on n'avait pas 9,0 et la fin du mois
il n'avait pas trop d'appréhension céreq
nice monte de deux divisions il était en
national l'année dernière donc on a
abordé ce match sérieusement mais on
avait quand même un bonbon ce qu'il
fallait en tout cas pour pour assurer
deux victoires et on les a faits les
voyelles vous êtes d'accord
oui je suis d'accord c'est ça fait bien
de commencer la saison comme ça avec
deux bonnes victoires mettre l'équipe en
confiance président victoire qui me
satisfait oui bah c'est satisfaisant
effectivement que commencer sur deux
victoires en championnat c'est toujours
assez intéressant on a une nouvelle
formule avec des matches qu'il faut pas
rater contre les promus qui ne vont pas
nous rater donc oui satisfaits alors les
joueurs avaient à coeur vraiment de
débuter cette saison alors cadre il vous
allez faire la traduction pour ailleurs
franck et c'est un menteur ans qui
parlent espagnol
c'est un mot qui va pas
nérac a annoncé la nasa l'équipe dit que
l'équipe d'être motivés qui est il et ça
me fait plaisir de avoir une autre pour
nous pour ce n'était avec les cougars et
cette saison essayer de faire mieux que
l'année dernière
alors vous auriez pu mieux faire sur
cette partie en tant qu'hôte j'imagine
que oui
le match contre nice ce match contre
nice
oui on en aurait sûrement plus faire
c'est vrai que c'est toujours un
démarrage c'est la reprise pour tout le
monde à la taxe est vrai qu'on a on a eu
une petite baisse de 2 une petite baisse
en deuxième
en deuxième match mais non c'est elle et
c'était ce qui est plutôt bien joué face
et les lanceurs surtout qu'ils ont fait
leur travail sur monticule
c'est ce qu'on attendait ce que
j'attendais aussi moi c'est savoir
comment les lanceurs allait s'approprier
ses deux premiers matches c'est
important au début de saison ça voir un
peu comment ils sont s'ils sont assez à
l'aise pour entamer cette saison ils ont
fait ils ont fuit le travail à la taxe
est vrai qu'on aurait pu être un peu
plus percutant mais ça va venir ça va
monter avec je pense qu'avec d'autres
équipes
quand on va rencontrer ses nerfs par
exemple dans quinze jours c'est vrai
qu'on a l'habitude de les jouer ni son
je la rochelle aussi la semaine
prochaine qu'on a on connaît mais c'est
vrai qu'on ne connaît pas les équipes on
est toujours un peu sur le sur la
défensive mais on a fait on a fait quand
même ce qu'il fallait il ya voyelles les
automatismes sont déjà là oui ça
commence à venir ça commence à venir
parce que l'équipe 1 c'est presque la
même qu'on avait l'année dernière malgré
les départs et les 3,9 sueur mais sinon
ça reste un compact l'équipe soi même
donc vous avez des nouveaux joueurs
cette saison président l'effectif bouge
peu finalement trois nouvelles recrues
est ce que c'était un choix aussi de
votre part de garder un effectif stable
qui avait prouvé la saison passée
qu'elles pouvaient prétendre au titre on
a durant l'intersaison en fait la
question qui s'est posée c'est de savoir
ce qui n'avait pas été la saison avant
de pouvoir combler un petit peu les
trous qu'on avait constaté et d'orienter
vraiment leur traitement sur ces aspects
là après effectivement on a eu quelques
départs qui n'étaient pas tous prévus ou
anticipés donc il a fallu combler aussi
bon après comme on vous l'avait dit on
est on a des moyens aussi qu'ils sont
assez cadré assez limité donc on fait
aussi avec ses éléments sur franck est
ce que vous sentez plus fort que la
saison passée est ce que l'équipe vous
sentez l'équipe plus forte que la saison
passée que tous étaient là qui pour ma
foi takanaga pas ça fait pas trop mal
malgré le départ de l'année dernière les
gens qui sont arrivés sont bien rentrés
dans l'équipe i
nous demandons toujours le 100% et que
ça se passe bien alors avant de parler
des objectifs du club pour la saison va
écouter vos supporters ils nous disent
ce qu'ils attendent de vous cette saison
qui remporte le championnat
et qui retourne en finale l'année
dernière phrase est en finale si j'ai
pas de bêtises donc qui retourne en
finale et qui gagne qui gagnent la coupe
d'europe à brno mois de juin ça serait
super
en championnat qui gardent leur place en
finale ce serait comme l'année dernière
ça serait super après peut-être battront
c'est possible voilà des belles
victoires simplement voilà bah ouais
déjà ce serait pas mal
je suis très très optimiste pour la
saison à venir il ya une très bonne
cohésion groupe et je pense que le
travail de cet hiver va payer on est
encore plus loin cette année non
seulement nationale et puis aussi
d'europe ça rodolphe le mur ils ont
l'air très optimiste oui si on entend
les interviews ouais ça fait plaisir
c'est vrai qu'on a on fait en sorte de
d'avoir une équipe soudée de continuer
dans la dynamique qu'on avait l'année
dernière c'est vrai que le titre nous a
échappé en finale contre rouen la grosse
machine roi mais cette année on veut
vraiment vraiment aller chercher ce
titre est aussi l'objectif de la coupe
d'europe qui qu'on a en tête
donc il faut il va falloir à lycée de
l'europe c'est vraiment un objectif ou
c'est un bonus c'est un bonus mais on
veut quand même faire quelque chose on
pense qu'on peut on peut réaliser
vraiment avec les équipes en place
on va où ça va être très dur parce qu'il
y en a quand même va avoir affaire à des
semi pros donc ça va ça va nous changer
du championnat français mais on a cet
objectif en tête c'est vrai de
représenter au mieux et la france et le
club en coupe d'europe
président vous sentez vous avez plus de
pression peut-être que les dernières
n'ont pas forcément plus de pression
s'est jusque là on est remonté ya
quelques années on a fait une très bonne
première saison sur la remontée
l'année dernière on fait la finale donc
du coup on est très attendu on n'est
plus du tout prix comme un club qui qui
fait des performances de temps en temps
maintenant on est vraiment attendu tout
le temps et on a vraiment repris une
place dans le trio de tête français
prochain match contre les boucaniers de
la rochelle ce sera un bon test gabriel
oui bien sûr nous sommes pas se préparer
avant le match contre senna mettre
l'équipe encore en plus en confiance
parce qu'ils essaient les équipes à
battre un sénat il faut pas des matchs
contre la rochelle entre un escompte de
cycle comme sa victoire
quoi qu'il arrive je crois que l'airé
merci à tous les cas dépasser sur ce
plateau vous souhaitez terminer champion
en fin de saison ne manquera pas de vous
suivre sur tv 78 ailleurs franck
reviendra pour parler français si
l'équipe
le championnat merci leurs banques
on continue par du football et le
championnat de d1 de district ce
dimanche plaisir s'est incliné 3 1 face
au fc mantois le chesnay remporté son
duel sur le terrain de montesson 2 à 0
maurepas et surtout ils se sont
neutralisés 1 partout à gricourt
s'impose 2 à 0 contre guyancourt match
spectaculaire mais match nul 3 partout
entre cariat grésillons et gargenville
enfin à marier le roi s'impose à
l'extérieur contre ou et qui reste tout
de même leader du championnat on
continue par le championnat de nationale
3 de football direction versailles les
joueurs de la cité royale se sont
nettement imposés 3 0 à domicile face à
brétigny ce dimanche une solide victoire
qui leur permet de remonter dans le top
5 du championnat à six points du podium
après 19 journées à disputer
je vous propose maintenant de retenir
votre respiration le franco cubain andy
cabreira avila a réalisé un nouveau
record à la piscine de saint cyr l'école
après avoir nagé en apnée dynamique
pendant six heures et 12 heures cette
fois ci il ne respirait que 4 minutes et
12 secondes en six heures en apnée
statique
un défi qu'il s'est lancé pour dénoncer
la maltraitance des animaux fonds marins
dans les parcs aquatiques en montage de
sandrine fontaine 14h15 au centre
aquatique de saint cyr l'école la piste
andy cabreira avis lie dans la dernière
heure de son record une performance de
six heures sans interruption le franco
cubain temps de respirer le moins
possible dans une cage pour dénoncer le
traitement des animaux marins dans les
eaux c'est quelque chose de très très
compliqué à gérer sur le plan d'eau
la respiration de la récupération
la gestion de l'effort donc c'est
quelque chose de très exigeant et qui
nécessite une très très bonne
connaissance de soi une performance
qu'il accomplit sous les yeux d'une
dizaine de supporters déjà c'est très
impressionnant parce que tenir comme ça
le mental est sûrement très très fort
donc on est vraiment sous le charme fait
dans 10 c'est difficile
mais
je pense qu'il a les capacités pour y
arriver dix minutes avant la fin du
record le clan dandy cabreira est
optimiste
très bien il est même en avance par
rapport à son entraînement il s'était
échauffé une première fois il avait fait
6 heures une première fois il est très
en avance par rapport à autant qu'ils
l'avaient fait précédemment
15h15 andy réussi officiellement son
record son temps de respiration et de 4
minutes et 12 secondes sur six heures
d'apnée il ya beaucoup de choses qui
bougent a voulu à côté c'est dans ce top
sur la spree c'est difficile mais moi
c'est autant d'avoir fini j'ai pas aux
gains de capacité pulmonaire donc j'ai
joué ma force de volonté et ses dégâts
des montagnes et des pensées a comme aux
nageurs espère également avoir réussi
son autre défi sensibiliser le grand
public sur la cause animale
tu me mets dans la peau d'un enfant qui
doivent vivre en liberté et nager 5 km
par jour et c'est nourrir des poissons
vivants
alors être tous la vie à peu près du
tout impressionnée simplement pour le
plaisir des justes les messages et la
l'histoire entre andy cabreira vilain
les records n'est peut-être pas encore
terminée le sportif a déjà évoqué l'idée
de replonger pour de nouvelles
performances à couper le souffle
retour sur terre pour parler au rugby
dans le championnat de fédérale 2
plaisir s'est incliné sur le terrain du
rheu ce dimanche lors de la 20e journée
du championnat le score 26 à 22 une
défaite qui pourrait avoir de lourdes
conséquences au classement et pelé 0 à
100 pour l'instant avant dernier avec un
match en moins à quatre journées de la
fin du championnat on continue à part du
rugby mais trois divisions plus bas dans
le championnat de promotion honneur
montigny-le-bretonneux a perdu pied sur
le terrain de bari les montants se sont
inclinés 41 à 10 face à des adversaires
directs ces derniers leur passent devant
au classement
la smb se retrouve maintenant troisième
à deux points de la deuxième place comme
on peut le voir enfin en division
honneur le scar xviiie a lui aussi perdu
les hommes de thomas payen se sont
inclinés sur le terrain du red star ce
dimanche sur le score de 24 à 18
une défaite qui condamne sûrement les
saint quentinois la septième place dans
cette poule avec un bilan de dix
défaites cinq victoires et un match nul
depuis le début de l' ac
on termine ce tour d'horizon au rugby
dans les yvelines par une note très
positive le rugby-club de versailles
fêté ce week-end la montée en fédérale 3
devant ses supporters et les joueurs
l'auront fait plaisir en l'emportant 37
à 12 face à clichy leur 16e victoire en
16 matches disputés pour vous parler de
cette magnifique saison qui restera dans
les annales du club
nous recevons sur ce plateau deux
dirigeants fabien 30-30 et pierre
chevallier responsable communication
ainsi que le capitaine jean à la mairie
les joueurs chalain gants doan nicolas
vous teniez ainsi que thibault le
boucher conçoit alors avant de parler du
résultat de ce match on va parler de
l'ambiance à l'été comment pierre
chevalier elle était elle était
fantastique était vraiment vraiment
électrique le cube qui est notre notre
club de supporters et à versailles
depuis maintenant un an et demi c'est un
groupe de d'anciens joueurs de copains
de joueurs de joueurs de l'as dès qu'il
joue qu'il joue pas et qu'elle joue pas
ce biais c'est sur les dimanches tous
les matches prévus et ça apporte une une
vraie ambiance une vraie identité dans
le dans les tribunes ça a amené un
nouveau public à versailles public
familial publique amicale et là sur ce
sur cette journée là un peu particulière
puisqu'il s'agissait de fêter
officiellement à la maison la montée en
fédérale 3 ils nous ont fait sauter le
stade et ça a été absolument absolument
fantastique avec des chants avec des
encouragements avec un clapping le
capitaine habituel et je pense que
joueurs ont dû sentir cette énergie sur
le terrain et c'était vraiment un des
grands grands moments jean la mairie
justement vous l'avez senti cette
énergie sur le terrain ouais évidemment
alors le club avait tout fait pour que
ça soit une grande fête en jouant le
samedi soir et ça a permis à tous ces
jeunes là de venir nous voir jouer
légende a dû d'écoles de rugby les
parents les dirigeants des partenaires
donc c'était une super fête et et ça ça
on s'en souviendra je pense ce lundi
deux joueurs alors nous avons justement
interrogé des supporters dans les
tribunes pour montrer que c'est en fait
le rugby c'est vraiment une famille
universelle c'est vraiment une famille
on a monté ça pour eux parce que voulait
trop fier du parcours qu'ils ont fait
est incroyable et juste chiant kiffante
ans j'ai déjà plus de voix il reste
encore plus de trois quarts du match
mais ça vaut le coup de feu on est joint
aux supporters c'est pour les copains
qu'on fait ça nous on adore ça l'a fait
3 l'an prochain ça va être le feu ça va
être dingue match déplacé dans tout le
quart nord-est de la france ça va être
terrible on va emmener la ans l'ambiance
partout on a chopé la normandie mille
dans pas de calais tout ça on est
ensemble ils vont aller de barthou ans
fabien oui venir de partout et oui
viennent ils viennent par tous déjà et
dernière sur le parcours du on a fait un
quart de finale du championnat de france
et il nous suivait ça met une grande
énergie et moi ça fait quelques années
je suis au club avec pierre notamment et
on n'a jamais vu ça c'est formidable
il ya un engouement on est reine de
beaucoup licencié au club sont et 600
licenciés et aujourd'hui on a un club de
supporters c'est formidable justement
comment il explique cette ambiance à
versailles qu'on retrouve finalement pas
dans tous les clubs de rugby des
yvelines je vais dire une banalité mais
en ami on a mis l'accent sur les valeurs
du ori vie tout simplement
avec l'arrivée de l'arrivée de derry
tournier le nouveau président avec
pierre et pierre et moi même on avait
voulu voulu remettre un peu les valeurs
du rugby
tout ce qui tourne au rugby depuis
depuis depuis de longues années donc
voilà la fête la fête c'est important
l'europe je pense que le groupe vit très
bien et est
j'espère qu'on annonce de grandes choses
l'année prochaine sa copine à
l'échappement tcc des copains les
copains qui jouent qui jouent pas qui
font qu'ils font au noyau dur comme ils
n'ont comme ils l'ont dit sur les
différentes interviews leur famille leur
bande de copains et tous nouveaux
publics dont on parlait et qui fait que
en plus avec la une saison particulière
où les seniors de la première gagnent
tous leurs matches il ya il ya un ya un
contexte très favorable à ce que est ce
qui est de l'ambiance autour des valeurs
et autour de ce que de ce à quoi on
croit
et en plus quand ça va au bout et pour
l'instant invaincus et avec la montée en
fédérale 3 ça mobilise les foules
tivo le boucher ce que vous pensez que
ça peut pousser certains joueurs à venir
au club les joueurs extérieurs away s'en
sortir dans mes en serait sans aucun
doute il ya vraiment une belle une belle
dynamique
moi je suis le petit nouveau du club je
suis arrivé depuis peu de temps et je
suis très impressionné par cette
ambiance par cet esprit de corps par cet
aspect de club
et effectivement je pense que ça va
cette belle dynamique qui va attirer du
monde c'est sûr alors on a le sentiment
que vraiment c'est tout un club
vous l'avez dit qui pousse est-ce que
vous entre vous vous en parler après les
matches de ce type d'ambiance on ne
parle forcément surtout qu on a vécu des
choses fortes si ces dernières saisons
avec versailles avec des dés quand même
des beaux parcours en championnat de
france que ce soit là une l'année
dernière en quart de finale l'abbé il ya
deux ans en demi finale ça soude est
vraiment une équipe qui une bande de
copains surtout et voilà il n'y a pas de
clivage
enfin équipe première équipe b c'est
vraiment chacun soutient que ce soit la
première pour la baie où l'abbé pour la
première et on le retrouve vraiment sur
le terrain nicolas et on va revenir sur
ce match et ce qui était si simple que
ça ce match contre vichy
l'entamé de match était pas simple
victoire 37 à 12 l'antenne de match
était pas simple mais quand on versait
se dérouler son jeu a su mettre son jeu
en place
ils ont su à la fin les mettre à bout
quoi ils ont su dérouler ils ont marqué
trois essais je pense en 15 minutes
donc non non c'était c'était compliqué
au début mais à la fin ils ont su
dérouler c'est important justement de
mettre en place
2 vous gagner avec un score fleuve
justement cette partie de ses actifs
c'est à ces joyeux qui s'est vérifiée
d'ailleurs par la suite n'en fallait pas
dérapé sur ce match là il fallait qu'on
gagne
c'était important la manière était de
mise en deuxième en deuxième mi-temps
essentiellement l'apport du banc a fait
beaucoup de bien parce qu'on en parle de
groupe sur l'ensemble du club mais la
science dans cette équipe première il ya
un vrai groupe qui qui apporte à chaque
moment donc l'apport du banc de ça fait
vraiment du bien capitaine la 3ème
mi-temps elle était comme un belle
famille en a bien profité et maintenant
assaillants bascule sur sur la suite et
de championnat ile-de-france sur
placement ce qui va arriver
justement la suite c'est quoi ouverte la
voie de la suite il ya trois ou venir la
vie qui vient en mangeant il ya trois
possibilités des trois possibilités de
faire vraiment cette saison une saison
record la première c'est terminé les
mâts dès les matches de poule invaincue
il reste deux matchs à domicile à
l'extérieur c'est à notre portée on peut
faire 18 sur 18 c'est du moins ce que
les escaliers c'est l'objectif
18 sur 18 matches maintenant oui
maintenant ça peut être un objectif
avoué celui là il peut être à vous et
c'est déjà arrivé dans l'histoire du
club j'avais des records ces 17 sur 18
ou pas très loin mais invaincu en match
de poule c la pression a maintenant
jamais rien le deuxième c'est de d'aller
chercher deux titres en ile de france
on jouera les demi finales pour la
réserve et pour la première le 21 avril
à priori à versailles
donc là pour se qualifier pour la finale
et d'aller chercher deux titres de
champion ile de france
ça non plus ça ne s'est jamais fait la
réserve a été championne ile de france
il ya deux ans charb le rappeler et puis
un troisième objectif c'est d'aller plus
loin possible en championnat de france
après c'est la dernière étape le record
du club actuellement pour une équipe
première c'est un quart de finale donc
au moins une demie aller chercher un
titre
il y aura des gros gros clients sur le
sur le trajet puis là c'est une autre
paire de manches mais en tout cas
d'aller le plus loin possible et 2
taillé une belle aventure entre copains
puisque c'est qu'a commencé en septembre
et qui on est allé chercher en raison et
peut-être jusqu'au mois de mai au mois
de juin sur le passé vous avez
l'effectif pour réussir ses objectifs
je pense qu'on a l'effectif on a aussi
ce qui fait que notre sport est aussi
beau des copains qui se battent pour le
même objectif et c'est ça je pense qui
fait qu' on peut aller très loin
i la fédérale 3 dernière question ça
sera quoi l'objectif en fédérale 3 alors
il faut qu'on en parle un petit peu dans
l'année prochaine mais un peu trop tôt
la problématique c'est de monter en
fédérale 3 c'est très très compliqué de
monter en fédérale 3 donc ce qu'il faut
surtout pas redescendre après il ya ya
ya ya ya un objectif qui va être qu'il
va être défini très rapidement mais le
maintien c'est le milieu syndical
maintien voire plus l'avenir nous dira
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau la
saison n'est pas encore terminée il
reste des titres à aller chercher on l'a
bien compris on vous souhaite de tout
rafler pour vivre de nouvelles émotions
stade de porchefontaine on va maintenant
prendre un peu de hauteur dans ce set 8
sport pour parler d' escalade la salle
de bloc verticale art basée à montigny
le bretonneux depuis cinq ans organisé
ce samedi 23 mars une grande journée
festive pour annoncer en grande pompe la
rénovation du site
dix jours de travaux et cent mille euros
ont été nécessaires pour changer et
améliorer les parcours et pour créer une
structure type ninja warriors on écoute
les réactions au micro de marylène yapi
chinois ça va faire parler un peu plus
de vertical art notamment dans la région
parisienne
qu'on ait connu pour notre qualité des
structures elle a de la remettre au goût
du jour les gens vont aimer encore plus
et brown et de jean gé nial trop belle
encore plus si les cavs ont déjà avec le
niveau est assez aux gens nouvelle prise
ça glisse pas du tout c'est un régal
c'est mieux
aulas au début je m'entraîne cherche à
pau les nouvelles vous
ils sont bien
marcio pour la cinquième fois de son
histoire et pour la première fois depuis
2008 le club d'aïkido de montigny le
bretonneux organiser ces journées
internationales
au programme deux jours de stage dédié à
cet art martial défensif et non-violents
japonais de grands maîtres sont venus
d'angleterre d'allemagne d'autriche et
de belgique et de france pour l'occasion
au total 10 heures d'aïkido ont été
proposées une soixantaine de pratiquants
l'écoutent l'un des organisateurs au
micro de tv 78 ce stage là a pour but de
développer l'amitié
l'aïkido n'étant pas compétitifs
l'esprit de ces stages c'est la
rencontre et c'est de créer du lien avec
les autres donc on crée des liens
d'amitié avec nos amis étrangers
et cette année c'est à montigny
peut-être l'année prochaine ce sera dans
un autre pays
on passe maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
ce sera l'un des rendez vous à ne pas
manquer cet été dans les yvelines
surtout pour les passionnés de cyclisme
la dernière étape du tour de france 2010
9 partira de la commune de rambouillet
traversera le sud du département un
événement rendu possible grâce à un
partenariat signé entre le département
et les organisateurs à montage de
sandrine fontaine le tour de france
passera par les yvelines au minimum
jusqu'en 2023 les organisateurs et le
département signé une convention en ce
sens ce mercredi 20 mars
objectif préparer les jeux olympiques
2024 avec notamment un départ en 2023 du
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines toutes les
épreuves cyclistes qu'elle soit à
l'intérieur du vélodrome doit
d'extérieur le bmx le vtt le vélo sur
route tout se tient dans les unir
il était donc pour une logique de
préparer ce très grand moment
on reverra pas les olympiques en france
avant des décennies
et donc
le département veut monter en puissance
pour les organisateurs ce partenariat
avec les yvelines marque une continuité
dans l'histoire du tour de france le
tour de france dès sa première édition
en 1903 est passé sur le territoire des
yvelines c'était la seine et oise à
l'époque
juste avant l'arrivée de la dernière
étape et c'est d'ailleurs le vainqueur
du tour de france du premier tour de
france maurice guérin qui avait gagné
cette étape là donc à tas d'histoires
qui sont passés dans le département en
une échappée formidable de bernard
hinault avec son rival all day of the
tomek voilà jusqu'aux dernières éditions
pour cette première collaboration dans
ce partenariat rambouillet a été retenue
comme ville départ de la dernière étape
vers paris le dimanche 28 juillet une
première depuis 2012
donc on attend bien sûr beaucoup de
monde 40000 spectateurs en 2012
on va essayer de battre le record on
attend du tourisme on attend une image
rambouillet est déjà connu au niveau
international la dernière étape est une
des étapes les plus regardées du tour de
france donc voilà c'est l'image
l'identité de rambouillet qu'on ait
cette magnifique identité qu'on veut que
le monde entier connaît ça après
rambouillet le peloton devrait passer
par la vallée de chevreuse jouy en josas
but qu'avant de quitter le département à
vélizy villacoublay
il y aura du football ce week-end dans
les yvelines en première division de
district les supporteurs auront le droit
à un alléchant derby entre guyancourt et
plaisir au stade maurice baquet avantage
aux bleus en courtois classé 5e du
championnat tandis que les plaisirs oil
luttent pour leur survie
le match est programmé à 15h on continue
cet agenda par de la course à pied la
deuxième édition du semi-marathon de
trappes c'est bientôt plus de 400
coureurs devraient prendre le départ le
dimanche 14 avril à partir de 9h30 le
parcours prévoit notamment une boucle en
pleine nature dans l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines des courses de
10 km et pour les enfants sont également
au programme si vous voulez vous
inscrire il reste encore des places
et on termine par de la boxe tony hawk à
originaires de chanteloup les vignes
dans les yvelines sera de retour en
juillet après une suspension d'un an
vainqueur de ses cinq premiers combats
chez les professionnels chez les lourds
le boxeur de 26 ans veut maintenant se
tester au meilleur il envisage même de
combattre contre l'actuel champion
invaincu anthony joshua fin 2020 début
2021 ainsi ses prochains combats sont
concluants on en saura plus dans les
approches un mois
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
il